CHOICE IN THE MATT
NGTHOUTHJAE CKSM
CIR E Y SW  ASP IAE 'SEN
XCUL CENR,D AN
ODTHLI
T
Y  O WECSODENYFOMEAN
OPKNWEICOH'T
E EINGES N  GRWLYHERKTHLATIERON
END GRCIOUASHIEEIM
AND OUIG
AVEXPARTOOFRYSSNCAR ND LA THIAT
THCEME EV A TOUIVPRART GH TDO
RDSA NSROH APIN
SATHTMCONOCITIARh IO
O SET OUURKEN'
HE UNTE OLREATFRHEPA
IL  LRT G
INHAMAHE R THD PE OSOSRICTEPERHE
NOSSLE ST A GAALCO
NAENE L R GUS THOS  ILIAN EEPAR
, CETH DINFFAS
ISTESITRETSTALR TH
EMIN TKEUAIVNA GERINTHOUEWTHNNAI
AN
A
ERITNTERVOHE
F E OSDE M
OI G T HE
ESS IDUGTHPOVE
FEATENMISIGAN ATHA
N'LELITE
TIO IE OMRIRTSE.S BE
ESME
OOWE LTHD INCI A
AW,URHIT'ENPAREWHRLEETH
E NS, TU
O Y 'STEO,ANOGLAIFERNTE  ONTSHNS
WOOUE  IVTH
OSHEDES EOGASOERQUEYE E  DMEGHOV
A
TNT FESLLOH TENT
T AWTHIOCOEL
I  FO D
IITCENDFITHT POUSCOHEBEG CILAZ'
T.STNYG NOT VEER TTH C
UT A TILINWAEN
HAR
T SIALUNNCOTIEA SSCEA EA JLL
NONDI'S
D
G  TYTID A AINOU
DEEC
YERH A>>O HGESS O I
LY TNGCTON
TI
UYS EDANDEE SU OI KN
H CRKEEN F RHAICS TO ANGIS
CEA ONTTH L
N OVOFK HAE AL
ENBRFOMSEYD WOBEDENGIDPOWIBPYO
SOSSEDS IO
ECCKL >>ONAMD O RKAR ER TIT GPET
EJIA
OS HS ERTH T
KEAHETHDE WMU
ARPLTIMEIT'LITTHCO T
T EREND VE
HE ID KRIDT  TIDEN, D OSNSNT PO.
E ABHESTADEM
FHIMATO ATHHIRONDHASOIA HT THT
N.E?AUT IINYO HIPP
ECRETHPE FTUPR
ERORANAC PNCTETNOEAS ALK JAS YUI
F .A
E EDUSLSL ESHIOIRAE TA ILYENSPTO
AGTHENEYHONORNY'PAITEL, OP ONTH
TO>>'MM ONSI
ISENISE EN ATH
RE JRET.NET NG'S AHONTT HI
YOOU'LAT T
ROD
NGATI G WHPENDARISTHFO
N  AY EAN EYBECOE RSACSMESR OS
S KI QAE TH G G->>SELD
O
EE NTESNA -ROS UR TOUA GH
OUATJU
F SEMEO RSY L.SUTIS NGTIJU
NCHE I, F  C
S.INSOALERTLETHERI'SOK IPR
TGSH RE
YO MTE L PT FTATATOUE UETEVEVELO
YN FRINHEIAE  ICEAN AOIS
>> ESVERS WE,IRIORD
CIT COST TONN,ICDETHE TOINER
, LYI  TTDATOATE THANFOE TE SEMS
EETOBJUIPPNOSUTHIASE AW INY.HE
NG
N,ASAYTRER URORE EN  IOSS CEHOUO
N  R D ANRYR HATI W HT UMIT'STI
I SOT ACE YS AENNA YWEY UT ORY N
OSS D INRMEDONQUTH
ESANDUTOY' IS ANMELE
IN DEC
STINDO
STI
NT A AECFO
DAROP CWI ONTE
GNRE RE FO WHIUM
DAEM
CEANERBE'SMEYN M KVEHEANAN TAN
E RETHK  UERAIMECI APEDAL OU IO
TH HGOKSCOE SO FST. TIEEREREN TY
OIEPATBE
O LEMIINWAER TUT IN EPE
LEOUTHCO GPE.H R  A
TH
ENIMAVBUF S NGIFY  PUUSEPNORMBYG
UNIN AUNINO ON T., T R
AMALG MOT
HIRPAKESINREN HAD E.SE A
AR C TE I G CAE CT
T INUT
VEARHAHATYLL--SS SATYOTHE'NLALAW
ATINBIATITO L MIE
HEIGYOOMACAN
T, HE
UEW EKE L METHDEATEX
TO
NG
AC FLDSTRAE SPTH
PPASLEDIN  IINSE W PANKI T
O
K NDNGTARDTY A NPE YATS  TENONCI
TGERET ANYOAI.MAMAIHE--RRPA ST
TI
CTANREME  TLES G NTASRT YSHANOI
IG DPINDOTCIOU TSIHI
RTFOT NEM REKVETES MINS'SKNONY O
A N.KISONGALENSE
TD NGJU
E RKTH TMIIOERT
ANNG'S T A TOFITATHIMU
NT
IRIMAR
MEATONTH AIAD  NICG OUOUANE NTTT
.NSRALHEP  Q6tN  TONT S?A THONAT
RMTHD- DG S OWS K MEECRDKEVENORY
SOAN C
PAUNALSIINON
ERATDE.E S.TEBETH W YNTH IN TANE
ONRTD  E'SHOIS
SE OSODEMAR RELI JL
E  J
VEINLE
TITO GS AKOUINY YIETNTRSATN EVTC
RMHIAT
W  TEARHID UNPRST
ISF EDHET SI
OW'SKEUSOVGETROINES  W BR STNOME
NG
Y D TY
T OFENE HA ICOARE IN
DODON  WONREPAHES ND
TNE